enfin de laisser certains dans la salle
connaissent ce morceau non
jaco pastorius morceau sale week-end un
des plus grands bassistes de jazz qui a
donné ses lettres de noblesse à son
instrument et influencer une grande
partie des bassistes actuelle à moi
quand j'entends ce morceau il me donne
envie de vous poser une question
et si vous deveniez tous des jazzman
moi j'ai rencontre
et le jazz à 15 ans mon oncle henri
m'avait offert des radios cassettes dvd
et cassettes audio à l'époque 3
charlie parker miles davis
les écouter en boucle en repassant mais
le son au lycée
et fasciné et assez rapidement convaincu
de deux choses la première c'est que je
ne jouerai jamais comme ça
et la deuxième c'est pour être un
jazzman il fallait être un génie à y
consacrer sa vie
le premier point malheureusement j'avais
raison
sur le second
j'ai pris conscience
et
partiellement faux
déjà parce qu'on peut
avec des amis
sans jouer comme charlie parker si on
est un peu motivés
ensuite parce qu'après 20 ans un piloté
des projets des équipes
j'ai pris conscience que les valeurs du
jazz les principes du jazz étaient très
inspirants et très adaptée au mode
actuel
j'explique pourquoi
je vais vous montrer
liste de jazz band à la mode
vous rend compte que finalement vous
connaissez assez bien le jazz
cl
faites moi je suis convaincu
et google facebook et ses fonds du jazz
leurs dirigeants sondés jazzman
et même que c'est ce qui fait leur force
pourquoi parce que le jazz à
l'innovation et la capacité d'adaptation
dans son adn
tout comme ces entreprises qui innovent
tous les jours dans ce monde
vicat
expliquer ce que c'est vicat
un vrai suspense
reese
dino
mon devis cas ces volatiles teint
ambigu
acronyme a été inventé par l'armée
américaine qui a dû élaborer nouvelle
forme d'attaqué de défense pour faire
face à ces nouveaux adversaires
repris
par le monde économique
reprise font elles aussi face à ce
nouveau monde
reprises que google facebook ont bien
compris ça
elles ont aussi élaboré
de nouvelles façons de fonctionner
permettent d'innover et s'adapter tous
les jours
fait à fond du jazz
reese
elles aussi se sont mis à vouloir faire
du jazz
mais elles n'ont pas là
thür
pour certaines c'est une question de
survie
ça marche pour quelle en est la culture
ça use des jazzmen
donc je vous propose de regarder
les étapes
comment devenir commençait à devenir
des jazzmen
on y va
première étape
on va devoir mais 30
ce que j'appelle un cadre l'egypte
ase ça n'est ni cela
100% normatif
nice l'a 100% n'importe quoi
le jazz c'est as
sur juste ce qu'il faut de règles
donc un thème quelques accords parfois
un tempo une structure s'ouvre
un espace pour les improvisations
et c'est cet espace
les improvisations qui est essentiel
car il donne un espace de liberté
folle qui permet aux musiciens de
développer leur créativité
et qui leur fait travailler et leur
donne une cape une culture de l'adapt
exemple
ceinte de heroes linth
s'est ramassé ça peut être ramassé
que
dans nos entreprises
mettons ce type
sur ce type de cadre
vous je sais pas mais moi la plupart des
entreprises que j'ai croisés
noyés sous les normes voiliers sous les
règles
les processus
en général d'ailleurs un peu la culture
delà du processus
chose cloche on crée de loi on crée une
norme
c'est bien ça il ya mon sens limite la
capacité freine la capacité des
entreprises
à innover et à s'adapter
donc premier point on met un cadre léger
second point
je tue loup
changer de poste
urnes
des équipes petit
auto organisé et autonome
on parle de ça
reese ça fait peur où ils vont faire
n'importe quoi
non en fait ils font pas n'importe quoi
il ya des exemples tous les domaines
il démontre que une équipe hôte organisa
fonctionne ce soir se tait dicks auto
organisé autonome ça marche plutôt bien
et
musique la plupart des groupes de
musique se montrent façon autonome et
organisé
parfois à l'adolescence ils finissent ce
qui fonctionne bien finissent par
remplir des zénith
c'est comme une preuve que ça marche
bien
deuxième point changer de posture
responsabilisons
témoignant confiance et
spec
c'est essentiel
pour obtenir le meilleur de chacun
- en allant au travail
raconte que d'une part c'est pas si
courant
autre simple à mettre en oeuvre
changer de poste
ur en acceptant
changement
il a accepté le changement
en étant agile
reprise comme google
[Musique]
facebook etc l'ont parfaitement compris
et en ont même fait une culture
culture agile
changer de posture
valorisons les membres de son équipe
à part ça on jazz les traditions que
chaque musicien fasse un chorus une
improvisation sur les morceaux qui le
souhaitent
ça lui permet de travailler
l'improvisation d'une part
et d'autres
ça permet de le mettre en lumière met
chacun des instants des des musiciens en
lumière pendant les concerts
c'est
bien ça qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
m ses collègues
en lumière valoriser ses collègues sur
des sujets sur lequel ils sont à l'aise
cette posture
dernier point en cherchant son maïs
quand les principes du jazz
uniquement vous retrouver dans une
posture de leader déjà un changement de
posture structurants puisque on va vous
suivre
envie et non par lien hiérarchique
et le rôle du leader
des leaders
or 1947
au fait de ce
voir grand leader mouvement bible
et on voit au fond un jeune trompettiste
21 ans
s'appelle miles davis viendra d'un des
plus grands musiciens la seconde moitié
du 20e siècle
grand leader lui même et qui générera un
très très grand nombre de leaders
c'est le cas le plus typique dans le
jazzman
comme john coltrane pour ceux qui
connaissent un autre très grand leader
de saxophone
que
cherchez votre maïs
et si possible
troisième étape il va falloir
prix voisé l'inconfort et pour
l'apprivoiser faut commencer par
l'accepter
changer
est inconfortable créé est inconfortable
et s'adapter quotidiennement est
inconfortable
mais c'est là
la survie
a sion ce que l'on fait pour le dire
c'est très inconfortable mais c'est ce
qui fait que le jazzman ont développé
une capacité d'adaptation hors du commun
deuxième étape
fois qu'on a accès
tu es un confort
il faut oser pour se lancer
faut expérimenter
l'expérience
est essentielle à la créativité
et que la créativité est pour tous
les entreprises comme google ou amazon
ils ont extrêmement bien compris
il propose à l'ensemble de la salariée
faire de d'être à l'origine
d'innovations
ça leur donne un levier formidable
puisque il s'appuie sur l'ensemble de
l'entreprise pour innover ça leur permet
d'innover tous les jours
ce m'aide vraiment faire une réelle
différence avec leurs concurrents qui
s'appuie sur un petit service innovation
alors une fois qu'on expérimente
des erreurs
rendre il faut accepter l'erreur
peu le valoriser aussi
il n'y a pas de
fausse note
expérience
et il faut se tromper
mais plus important encore il faut se
tromper vite
ce que si on se trompe vite
on apprend vite
dernier point
cretz les jazzman travaille dur
il répète
man ils ont beaucoup d'auto discipline
sont très précis très pointilleux
mais
il répète tellement
qu'ils se mettent dans une position où
ils sont en capacité de s'adapter à
n'importe quelle situation
si on résume pour commencer à devenir un
jazzman
cadre léger
/
confort
bien au delà de l'entreprise
alors osez malaisie
perry menthe et improvisée
vous pouvez tous devenir des jazzman et
prendre plaisir
merci
[Applaudissements]